[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here
pectober is getting pretty real right
this is my very first
like really truly first look
at pixel 5.
yeah fedex took their dear sweet time
with this one i don't know how they
always managed to find the worst
possible package to lose
and lose that one but anyway one loss
package and a lot of waiting later
let's get into it
so the story with this phone
is that it's a flagship
but not a flagship so what do i mean by
that well this is the highest end phone
google is putting out this year we saw
the pixel 4a we saw the 4a 5g and this
is the pixel 5 and there will be no
pixel 5 xl this is it this is the best
phone they'll offer but at the same time
it has a snapdragon 765g instead of the
highest end available chips it's got 8
gigs of ram and 128 gigs of
non-expandable storage
it doesn't have tons of bells and
whistles and there's a 90 hertz display
again instead of 120. and so the result
maybe the most interesting part about
this is the price
6.99 so yeah okay in a world of all
these phones flying north of a thousand
two thousand dollars uh the highest end
pixel phone seven hundred bucks so my
question going into it is
will i care or even notice that the
flagship bells and whistles type stuff
are missing from this phone because
google is going to put the best they can
in this phone for the price because they
don't make a better one that they have
to protect how good is it and do i care
about the differences so this video is
just my first look and impressions of
the trade-offs that they've made they're
actually i'm not gonna call them
trade-offs i'm gonna call them cuts
they're intentional cuts the last
version high end was 900 bucks this one
is 700 bucks they've made cuts so
getting my hands on it for the first
time it's already a little different
than most of the other phones coming out
and that number one thing is this body
is made entirely of recycled aluminum so
it's unibody metal and then it has this
soft touch feel to it in this sage green
color you can see here and so that to me
feels like this sort of coating over the
top of the metal so technically the
build is a metal body and that's sweet
no seams unibody just one piece shiny
button
but it doesn't necessarily feel
like metal like it's not cold to the
touch or anything it feels like hard
plastic which isn't a bad thing and
there's even a tiny little bit of
texture you can feel on the back if you
rub your finger across it but it's
subtle but there's a couple more
interesting things about this metal
build
one is it still has wireless charging
and reverse wireless charging now as you
may know wireless charging works through
glass and through plastic but not
through metal so it seems like there's
got to be some sort of a cutout back
here on the back of the phone to allow
that to happen
and then number two there is water
resistance on this phone so this phone
will survive a little rain or a splash
and then number three there's also no
more squeeze sensitivity on the metal
body so that squeeze for assistant
feature from the previous two years of
pixel is cut and you know what else is
cut
soleil
the the radars and those sensors that
were up in the front of pixel 4 and 4 xl
are gone so the the face unlock and the
gestures that you would have had aren't
here anymore
but
that that's a good cut i feel like we
got some things back from that now they
did toss back a fingerprint reader on
the back of the phone which to me has
been the safest best place to put a
fingerprint reader and it is super fast
love that and then cutting all that
hardware out of the top has also left us
with thin uniform bezels all the way
around the phone which look way better
this is honestly i'll say it's the best
looking front of a pixel phone in years
which maybe that's not saying much
coming from the line that gave us
asymmetrical bezels and the bathtub
notch but pixel 5 is a good looking
clean front of a phone for 20 20. only
caveat here is you'll notice if you look
very closely there is no normal earpiece
speaker at the top of pixel 5. and we've
seen this before so pixel 5 looks to be
doing that vibrating speaker underneath
the glass thing so my first impression
of hearing and feeling it because you
can sort of feel it vibrate the top of
the phone is it isn't as strong of a
stereo image with that bottom speaker if
you really like listening to music very
loudly but it's not the worst thing in
the world and it works just fine
especially as an earpiece and then last
but not least getting rid of that soleil
sensor array also made room for more
battery inside the phone so pixel 5
despite being smaller than the pixel 4
xl has a much bigger
4080 milliamp hour battery up from 3700
now again this is this is my first
impression it's my first two days with
the phone so my battery has been pretty
good so far but that's something i'll be
keeping an eye on but yeah i can't be
mad at more battery like that is
significantly impressive for a phone
that's actually smaller than the
previous footprint but we all know the
cameras are the real draw of the pixel
phone and they have been for a few years
we have again here the same 12 megapixel
sensor from the last few years of the
pixel and it's joined this time by an
ultra wide so they've doubled back on
the whole ultrawides are fun but
telephotos are more useful stance so we
finally get a pixel ultra wide now and
i've been looking forward to seeing what
pixel 5 cameras could do both on the
regular camera because they've stuck
with this winning formula for so long
that the rest of the smartphone world is
kind of starting to catch up so i was
looking to see would they have anything
changed to stay ahead
and then the ultra wide because i was
waiting for so long to see what google
could do with an ultrawide and night
sight and all their image processing on
an ultrawide because frankly i thought
they'd do it best so definitely some
really good photos coming out of this
phone so far but stay tuned especially
on twitter and then for the full review
for those photo samples as i take them
and really the biggest changes that
they've actually promised from this
camera were for video and so far i'm
mostly noticing just stabilization
smoothing like a lot of it and this of
course will get more testing but for as
long as photos have been a high point
for pixel cameras video has been a
notoriously lower point so my attention
is definitely peaked here but yeah this
is this is the daily now my sim card is
in it i can test it and we'll see if i
can be totally fine living daily with a
765g phone without all the bells and
whistles of the flagships with in-screen
fingerprint readers and 120 hertz and
then also as i got this phone in the
mail from fedex finally i asked you guys
what you wanted to know on twitter and i
got some interesting ones so what's the
feel in the hand and does it feel like
aluminum or not and how's the size i
keep saying this is a this is a small
phone it's smaller even than the smaller
iphone 11 so it's not mini or anything
but it's a small phone and yeah like i
said it doesn't feel like aluminum it's
not cold to the touch or anything it you
feel the plastic how does it feel to be
the last tech reviewer to receive it
fedex man
fedex express if camera doesn't exist in
any phone then pixel can be seen as a
better competitor
oh i think okay i think what they're
asking is basically if if you took away
the cameras like would the rest of the
pixel be competitive with the rest of
phones
which that's an interesting question i
actually think that's part of why google
is
leaving that thousand dollar flagship
space like they tried for the last few
years that 900 000 phone thing didn't
really compete very well didn't sell
very well i think this is their
admission that they can't compete up
there and that they need to try a six
seven hundred dollar phone and do well
there now i still wish i think i'm gonna
still wish this by the end of my review
but i still wish that they made a
beefier flagship version with 120 hertz
and the biggest baddest chip and the
most ram and some extra features tossed
in there but
we'll see oh and how fast is the phone
with the pictures and the assistant
without pixel neural core so that's
another thing that they took out of the
previous pixel there is no dedicated
image processing chip on this phone so
there is a little bit more time to snap
photos and process them again here's how
long it takes to snap a regular photo
which is actually not so bad but if
you're taking a night site or something
that requires more stitching there can
be a little bit more processing which
again might not feel as premium but
that's what you get by cutting the
neural core but anyway there you have it
we'll get right into the full review
process and i'm sure that will be coming
up pretty soon along with all the other
stuff coming out because it's tectober
and it doesn't stop but uh let me know
what you think is this the type of pixel
you wanted to see or would you have
preferred to see
that bleeding edge high-end pixel
happened too let me know in the comments
below either way thanks for watching
catch you guys very soon in the next one
peace